i am bringing the night pants nation
tour to boston march 31st to april 2nd
and minneapolis april 28th through the
30th get your tickets for those shows
and all shows at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media i want to thank you guys as
i do every week for uh
watching for supporting i can't thank
you enough
uh this community continues to grow
and um it's i love my job man you guys
have made a huge difference in my life
so
um one thing you can do to help out the
show if you're watching hit that
subscribe button subscribe to youtube um
and the patreon man
that show's not going anywhere anytime
soon the stories are
unlike anything that's going on out in
comedy out there right now that's for
real all right it's five bucks a month
if you sign up for a year you get over a
month free you get the honey do a day
early ad free at no additional cost all
right if you or someone you know has
that story that has to be heard please
submit it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
and hopefully we can do an episode of
the honeydew with y'all all right night
pants nation tour continues i'll be in
boston march 31st through april 2nd and
minneapolis i will be there april 28th
through the 30th that's the biz you know
we do over here we highlight the
lowlights i always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers i'm very
excited to have today's guest here first
time on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome harlan williams
welcome to the honeydew harlan williams
lap it up bro clap it up
oh man i think i just gave myself uh
not a standing ovation but a like a
sitting
something
[Music]
just sitting something yeah that was
great yeah well it's great to have you
here it's so good to see you for real i
ran into at the store the other night
yeah you said i just thought about you
the other day about the
your podcast that he did and i was the
crab feast which was a great episode got
us in the harlem graphics episode and
you said we did it in your apartment i
said yeah and you said you still doing
it there yeah
yeah i just said it feels like it bro
but i'm still doing it there i love you
it was so funny because it was the only
podcast that ever
done where i was like in a big condo
complex
and i had to walk back through the yard
i think there was a couple of corpses
and it was just i felt like am i doing a
podcast or a dinner party like i felt
bad that i didn't bring cinnamon squares
or something you know i was just
i don't know it was oh it was
interesting but we had a blast a royal
black that was a great one had a royal
blast um well please before we get into
this episode plug everything and
anything you would like really yeah
absolutely well what i'm plugging now
i'm wearing
um
i'm doing this thing now where i draw my
own t-shirts and this is one of the
shirts i hand drew
and people love them i call it wearable
art and so i started a website called
harbling.com
okay harbling.com and all i sell are my
hand-drawn t-shirts is the fish lure
hand-drawn
that's a photo that's a special uh
photograph shirt i did for you because
you love fishing but i do but on hard
blanket you know i was selling these
hand-drawn shirts from time to time
and people were loving them and so
uh this is what i'm promoting are my uh
hand-drawn shirts and where can you get
that heartbling.com go on there and
there's all kinds of different there
you get the only one you get the
original you make prints but you get the
original piece of art and you get to
wear it so
no more brand names just
i love it dude you [ __ ] love it thank
you i mean i love it because back in the
day i remember this you know i i mean
i'm 48 so high school this is 90 91.
and earlier we wanted all we all wanted
a free james brown t-shirt we made free
james brown t-shirts a bunch of us and
we took the face he had this crazy face
that we found on the it wasn't even the
internet we found it in online or
whatever we we tried to print it out and
get it on the shirt it just looked like
[ __ ] yeah you know now everything looks
so good that looks really good thanks
man draw them with sharpie permanent
markers so you can wash the shirts
but uh wait that's drawn literally on to
the shirt right now i drew this yeah
this is this is not a print this isn't a
print this is the original oh no [ __ ]
that's like
it's like a wearable nft yeah basically
and i realized you know we don't really
talk about our scapulas that much you
know
we have two yeah there are two uh when
was the last time you had a good scapula
conversation so i thought is there a
good one and a bad one like azeroth yeah
yeah so this is scapula guy and he's a
scapula and
i hope it puts people in touch with
their scapulas
and also
puppy dog pals yeah yeah can we talk
about it how many seasons now we're on
our fifth we just started our fifth
season of puppy dog pals i love it
you're you're in my house all the time
my daughter watches puppy dog pals and i
try to tell her i'm like i know harlan i
know the guy that does that she's like
huh yeah we'll do a voice for later
we'll do we'll shoot a video and i'll do
bob's voice for her she'll love it yeah
so speaking of puppy dog pals what an
interesting segway i i asked you to uh
to send us a little list of your low
lights and you said there were three
significant deaths and two of those were
animals and one was a person so yeah i'm
gonna let you take the wheel here why
don't we start can we start with the
animals yeah yeah
um you know you you have moments pivotal
moments in your life that are intense
and uh can be emotionally hard to deal
with and experience and
um
i don't know about other people but you
know a lot of times it's a pet that can
really um resonate with you and and i
had this little puppy
that i had bought a little black
chihuahua with a with a white crest on
his chest and little um
white patches on his feet looked like he
was wearing a tuxedo or looks like maybe
his mom was a a penguin or something
it was weird because he wouldn't we'd go
out for walks by the lake and he'd dive
and come up with a fish
but i did name him fisherman bob that
was his name
bob for real okay and he was a little
black chihuahua and um
and
you know i it's a weird comparison but
you know in life people lose a kid
i can only imagine what it's like like
to lose a kid have a child abducted or
have a child die but
i was up at the house one night and you
know i just would leave the door open
and my two dogs would run in and out and
play and how old are you at this time uh
i was
this was probably when i was about uh
maybe
40. okay is it here in california you're
in cali and i live up in the hills and
you have two dogs i had two dogs and uh
one was a bigger dog like a husky and
then the other one was uh fisherman bob
and they'd run in and out i'd leave the
door open while i watch tv
and one night the big one runs back in
and looking a bit freaked out and
the little guy didn't come in fishermen
bob didn't come running back in and i
was like oh that's weird they're
inseparable
and uh i go out in the yard and i don't
see them i'm calling them and i'm like
something immediately felt wrong you
know you're right your ray your your
parent radar goes off and
and then i looked at uh i looked at the
white dog the husky and there was a
little splotch of blood
on the front of her her arm her lower
arm there and uh
shouldn't say arm dogs don't have arms
do they yeah they did i'd be getting a
massage from the bastards but
sometimes we do so much stuff you want
to go for a walk give me a rub down
challenge wouldn't it be some [ __ ] if
all long dogs could just never ask oh
yeah
because they get those pads which should
really feel really nice and then they
get the claws yeah yeah they could do oh
what a treat
i'd be getting the newman's own salad
dressing out every night and just say
okay get to work buffy or whatever your
name is
um so yeah i noticed blood on on my
other dog and what the hell is going on
and so i started calling and calling and
then slowly that sinking feeling
that
uh oh and then in the background during
all this something that i hadn't really
noticed before but i'm hearing an owl
i'm hearing an owl hooing and every time
it does the bigger dog's like freaking
out
and i'm like what the hell is going on
so then i get the flashlight out and i
start searching the yard and now i'm
yelling and now five minutes is turning
into 10 minutes and then
what time of night is this this is like
probably around 10 30 at night and uh
and uh and then it gets longer now i'm
out walking the street wondering if he
got away
and i come back and i realize
something's happened and then as i'm
standing in the air i hear this hooing
again
and the white dog flips out starts like
panicking and and i realized my little
chihuahua
a freaking owl came down
and took took
down
an owl man i thought you were gonna say
coyote for sure
i thought i wish i could a [ __ ] al
took it well a coyote would have been
better because a coyote would have
picked it up and shook it and killed it
right so the reason it's so traumatizing
is is you know i have to i don't even
want to talk about it but
you picture
an owl doesn't just kill something it
slowly picks away at it and eats it
alive
you're not hearing that are you i'm i'm
i'm seeing it in my head and i'm i'm you
know here's here's this animal that's
entrusted it's life to you you're you're
its protector
and you know i don't have kids so he was
kind of my kid and knowing
my little dog was just slowly stripped
a lot it's just like horrific yeah it's
awful and
people
often get mad at me because that night
it was a bit chilly out and i'd wrapped
them in bacon
i do
no
owls love
apples love bacon
no
no i'm trying
the only way i can get through it is to
joke about it that's what this show
is what this show is all about
but hold on let me just say this too in
your defense yeah out here you know you
you're from toronto you're saying i'm
from baltimore you learn a little bit i
i was freaked out the first time i drove
down coldwater canyon early one morning
and saw coyote just trotting down the
hill i had yeah i'm not used to i'm like
oh it looks like a it looked like a sick
dog and i'm like oh [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] coyote and then to see them in
such you know
real neighborhoods i i've heard it
before i've heard them get cats i've
heard those
and they're you just i shut the door
like that is somebody's cat's gone you
know so
you do everything you can with fences
with the this is what that a [ __ ] al
i mean that but that's an apex predator
out of the sky you ain't doing nothing
about it right yeah and i never thought
about that why would you yeah i never
thought about death coming from the poor
born yeah
you know what i mean
it's like it's like you know to a
chihuahua that's a pterodactyl
you know what i mean that's that the
chihuahuas is big and an owl's like it's
wingspan
you're in the land of the lost with a
puppy
you listen even if you were there you
can't there's nothing you can do that
owl's gonna [ __ ] go man and they're
powerful man those owls i i i have two
of them that live right by me and i'm
fascinated by and i'm sitting there one
night
and i can hear them i see them up there
so i start playing i figure out their
barn owls and i start playing barn owl
noises oh wow they start they'll start
to fly back and forth and i watch them
wow and one night i'm sitting there i'm
talking to evan she's on the balcony
with me we're having a smoke and the
[ __ ] i'm telling her i'm like i'm
telling you these [ __ ] things they
come down they fly
it was this if it was script and she
goes you mean this one right here this
[ __ ] flew down right like right
here and went right over us and i was
like oh wow [ __ ] so i wanted to put
something there to make it think
there was something small there and see
if we couldn't try to
get you to adopt a chihuahua
no i'm not gonna kill real i got that
little puppy what'd you put down there
though i found something on the um on
the internet that was wasn't uh like an
animal it was a like a home so it would
come and maybe nest there i was trying
to [ __ ] oh wow i was trying to make
an owl nest on my balcony
so you're gonna you're gonna have the
idea you're gonna welcome the thing that
ate my dog into your yard
okay i see hard i live in an apartment
bro oh my balcony yeah i see where this
is going
you let the murderer into your home
listen if you can't beat them yeah you
know what i'm saying you're one of those
uh you're one of those people that uh
kind of wants to help nurture them back
to not being a killer yeah yeah i got
yeah you know put them back in the
society
but that thing came so close it's like
eva i mean i in my mind she's like oh
you mean this one right here like like
she could have grabbed the foot like
even this one right here like yeah right
there that's amazing they get hurt i'm
telling you they're [ __ ] wild though
they're wild and they got those huge wow
like what did it weigh maybe seven
pounds six pounds and i never made that
connection you know i i never
i never thought about
a night predator from the sky you know
like i thought if anything another cat
or another dog could get it sure i
didn't even to be honest at that point
in time wasn't even aware of coyotes
yeah oh bobcats too yeah now now since
the uh abduction and the murder i've
seen i'm sorry you called them
um
it's an owl murder bro
yeah you're right
do you think you are
who does he think he
by the way owls have you ever had sex
with an owl
because i'm just saying whenever you
have sex
you know people
people's eyes usually go a little wider
when you do the insertion and owls their
eyes are already so big you can't tell
oh you can't tell you can't tell if
they're like oh you know they're all
ready but anyways i'm getting off track
yeah away yeah way off track all right
so let's go back to this so
you heard no noise though no nothing no
noise i was busy doing something at the
time and i feel guilty about that too
i was uh do you think the husky tried to
to fight what do you think it was scared
no the husky is a hunting dog it's
actually called a jindo it's a it's a
very rare breed in america but it was
it's a korean dog there's an island off
of korea called jindo and the king
back in the day they they bred these
dogs to be guard dogs and hunting dogs
for royalty
and they look like um albino coyotes
they're white and they're very pointed
and they just live
this this dog would sit in my window all
day and just look for any anything that
came on the property it attacked so
that's why i also know it wasn't a
bobcat or a coyote because it would have
been on its own right this had to have
come out of
nowhere and uh
but but later on
in in as about a couple of years maybe
three years went by i was clearing
bushes and hedges and i found fisherman
bob's little toy that he played with no
and it i'll tell you it just made me
relive the whole
did you break down i sort of almost did
to be honest you know it's like i feel
guilty that that was my kid
and i wasn't there
and like i said
just the way that he probably went it
it's just like so that's something that
really
lives with me that that's tough let me
ask you this harlan williams because
let's play it the other way around let's
say you were there
let's say you were standing right there
yeah that owl flew down
do you have an idea have you thought
about what you would try to do kick shoe
you're not shooting a [ __ ] it's
not a pigeon yeah
did that right that but then i don't
mean you but i want to finish this
thought but then
you witness
it go there's a real image in your head
instead of what you think happened what
would you rather live with not really
knowing and putting it together or
actually seeing that go down i'd
actually it sounds more but i wish i'd
seen it just so i could know for sure
and you know but either way the outcome
so i mean the one you're talking about i
might as well you know sit at home and
watch jeepers creepers that's what that
sounds like you're losing either way
you're losing yeah you're not beating it
out you're not beating it now and by the
way they they fly silently yeah they
don't they don't hear themselves
it's not like a lot of birds where you
can hear the flat they're engineered to
fly silent so they just come in like
ghosts and they're gone
but um
yeah so finding finding that ball was
just it just it just never leaves you
man
you feel like guilt you have pictures
around the house i have pictures of
fisherman bobby
what's your the husky's name
captain chili dogs
is it real
though i can't make fun of you our dog's
princess lily rose right so yeah that's
the beautiful thing about dogs you don't
if you try to tell my daughter like you
know if you give him a human name you
come off as an idiot hey george is here
no how about there's seven dish layer
lasagna
go throw the frisbee for lasagna you
said the kids she's like maybe i
shouldn't have named her that i'd go how
many dogs do you think in this world are
named princess lily rose yeah anyway
that's the beauty of them you get to
give them silly names so say again chili
captain chili dog and fisherman ball all
right how did captain chili dog change
after fisherman bob was gone
not much at all no no she she was she
was a prima donna so fisherman bob was
just a play thing for her but
she was very protective of fishermen bob
when they were alive
like one day a pack of dogs came towards
uh fisherman bob and captain tilly just
literally walked circles around her
snapping at every dock
the man yeah so she loved him but when
he was gone she was like okay where's my
food
you know what i mean yeah
it's really sad the way they just you
know move on dot com
dot org or whatever did you ever get
another dog i got a bulldog i got those
big the big fat bulldogs that's tough
right even even a blue heron couldn't
lift that off isn't it crazy right that
the purchase of your next dog you had to
consider whether an al could
had to consider an attack from the sky
yeah yeah
and i thought nothing's lifting that
thing up you know what i mean
i mean this is the fattest
damn thing i mean this is like a manatee
with lips
it's just like
horrible
you know i'll get in this one
anyhow that tried to lift that one up is
throwing out its kidney or something but
but uh so this new one was the names
with sailor i realized all my all my
dogs have a nautical name theme you know
so uh yes so that was the demand water
your big old fishing
fishing all right yeah
and uh what else i feel guilty about too
is
while
they were out
running around and
fisherman bob was lifting off into the
night sky
daddy was uh in the bedroom
having a little lovemaking
what makes it even harder it was
it was
doggy style
[Music]
i wish there was a drone that could see
doggies down and float outside your dogs
i'm so sorry and al took your dog
well come on i can't do doggy style
anymore without crying
crying
because what are those drops on my
buttocks i go those are salty fisherman
bob tears out tears
now keep riding honey
yeah it's uh it was uh i feel guilty
about that
r.i.p
never have i i considered not a dog i
mean a cat made sense to me but
i've seen those videos online too where
like eagles try to take a kid and [ __ ]
you know what i mean like that one was
from stage oh was it wrong
yeah but it was so convincing i i
actually saw the making of that
the making yeah there was because so
many people were fooled by that video
that somebody like deciphered it and
broke it down and but it was pretty
convincing that was convincing but i i
it's probably not out of this
on discovery i've seen who knows maybe
this is fake too but eagles grab a
[ __ ] like a mountain lion or or like
a smaller
mountain goat yeah or a fox yeah flying
them yeah yeah they're they're apex
predators man
they're uh raptors
man yeah i've never not you're the only
person i've ever heard who lost a dog to
an
[Music]
yeah i i did a movie once with an owl
you did and i had to do a scene where an
owl landed on my arm it's called the
eurasian eagle owl the biggest owls in
the world how much is this thing
weighing well that's what's miraculous
about them they only weigh about
four pounds oh really they're huge
because their bones are hollow they're
all most birds are all air
so this big bird it's like stood this
tall it lands and you can barely feel it
but it landed like this
and the handler he said grab the back
talon and pull it and i said are you
sure i don't want to hurt it he goes he
goes it was sitting on my arm he goes
pull it
and i pulled it and i go yeah and he
goes now pull it as hard as you can and
i said he goes pull it i tried to move
that thing you couldn't i couldn't
budget and he said that's what happens
when once these raptors get their claws
into something it's a death lock you're
done
damn yeah so holy smokes
now did you do the movie before or after
it was after oh so that was tough that
was it was harder finding the ball or
working with a an owl
this is tough
it was tough working with that owl
you were asking you asked about that
[ __ ] you're right right but the handler
was uh we had to stop rolling a few
times because he was like why are you
punching my owl in the face
yeah i was just like bam bam
and it was perched on i think so it was
swirling around like it was never like
around and it wouldn't let go and i'm
just like then i poked it in those big
[ __ ] round eyes and i got a little
payback
all right
okay well let me gather myself god
that is a very unique way to lose an
animal
it is i mean i know other people out
there are going to be exci there's
definitely somebody out there that's
going to probably share a story with you
i hope so
i think an al's going to get another i
think we could have like an owl pool owl
group therapy thing or something
um
tell me about the second animal
wow the second animal you know the
second animal was a mixture because it
was devastating to me maybe even more
than fisherman bob was there after
this was before this was probably
three years before
and
and i'm sorry did you have chili what
was his name again uh captain chili dog
no i didn't have any dogs at this point
okay cause i just moved into my first
house in hollywood up in the hills i was
leasing it
and on the back of the house was all
forested area and hills and all this
again back to you know
animals and stuff
and i was in my house one day and i
could hear this high-pitched chirp
almost like you know when uh when a
smoke alarms battery starts to go does
it beep or whatever it is
and i kept hearing this thing and was
coming from the yard
and i go out in the yard and i'm zoning
in and i look around and i find a little
baby squirrel
like just it's laying it's falling out
of the forest and it's laying on the
terrace and i'm
like oh my gosh and i i look at it and i
pick it up and and the things just
chirping it's obvious it's mother is
abandoning it and it's falling out of
the nest
and i'm like oh i'm gonna i'm gonna be
really big how big is it it was probably
like that big okay uh and and uh i'm
thinking i'll nurse this little guy back
to health and because i love animals you
know so i was really excited sort of
and then i looked down at its back leg
and there was a there was a gash in it
probably about that big like an open
wound i was like oh no and then i'm
looking at it and something's moving
and i look inside the wound and it's
just swarming with maggots oh no there's
probably 70 80 90 maggots inside and i
realize oh my god this little guy's
being eaten alive
and so now i go from being the savior to
i have to mercy kill this thing which i
don't want to do
and i'm thinking
how do i do it do i just drop a brick on
it do i splat it do like how do i cook
because i actually did that when i was
younger my sister had a pet mouse that
got some really weird disease where it's
it's butt blew up like a cauliflower and
i couldn't walk like it was just like
it's like leprosy meets sars you know it
was like animals do not have good luck
around you
so i bought an owl no
so
so i was like this poor mouse like it
couldn't move its back legs it was
pulling them it's like the back half of
its body was rotted basically
and i thought i'll do i'll go out and
i'll just drop a cinder block on it and
like i don't want to but i can't let it
live like this
so i did it and the cinderblock kind of
in the air it tilted
it tilted and it it kind of half
clonked the thing
so
now it can't walk its [ __ ] looks like
a cauliflower
and a cinderblock
just kidding enough not to kill him
now it's dragging around
and i'm just devastated right
it's like whatever some animals did they
send them to the williams house
it was like watching oh god yeah it was
like it was just a nightmare so i was
like i'm not going to drop
something on this baby squirrel
in case i miss or half hit it
so i thought what would be the most
peaceful way to put it down and i had
one of those big orange home depot
buckets you know the utility buckets
and i thought i don't want to but i'll
drown it i'll just like put it in the
thing
i'll put the hose in and it'll be a soft
gentle and
um
oh god i feel horrible now
should we just go out and kill a dog or
something
so
i put this thing down in the in the
bucket
and i put the hose in and i turn it on
and
i don't know if i'm an idiot but i
didn't know that baby squirrels floated
so as i'm filling the bucket
maggot boys floating up he's not he's
not he's not drowning he's a soldier
he's like it's like you're trying to
drown a life preserver it ain't going
down and and so
as the thing's filling up i'm like oh no
and so
i kind of used the hose to push him
under
and this little guy's grabbing the hose
and climbing up
[Music]
he's with his little cloth
and he's grappling up and he comes right
up and he's like oh he's breathing with
his buck teeth
you know
and i'm like god
can i not kill a rodent
who wears a [ __ ] owl when you need
one
where's the day owls can we get a day
owl
put some
get some contacts and fly you bastard
liquid ivs back y'all right here i'm
gonna show you right now this is it i'm
using it it's part of my everyday
morning routine that's the tangerine one
that i like right there i didn't just
litter but it is my studio i'll clean it
up
derek get that one stick liquid iv and
16 ounces of water hydrates faster and
more efficiently than water alone and it
comes in incredible hydration flavors
like watermelon lemon lime strawberry
pina colada and more and my favorite
here's that tangerine y'all
and it's good contains five essential
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c with
three times the electrolytes of
traditional sports drinks made with
premium ingredients non-gmo and free
from gluten dairy and soy and what makes
liquid iv so effective is the science of
cellular transport technology that ctt
y'all designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream grab
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com and use code honeydew at
checkout that's 25 off of anything you
order when you use promo code honeydew
at liquidive.com experience better
hydration today at
liquidive.com promo code honeydew
today's program was brought to you by
athletic greens the health and wellness
company that makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really really simple with so
many stressors in life it's difficult to
maintain effective nutritional habits
and give our bodies the nutrients it
needs to thrive busy schedules poor
sleep exercise the environment work
stress or simply not eating enough of
the right foods can leave us deficient
in key nutritional areas i'm taking
athletic greens every day one tasty
scoop of ag-1 contains 75 vitamins
minerals and whole food-sourced
ingredients including a multi-vitamin
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more in one convenient daily
serving the special blend of high
quality bioavailable ingredients in a
scoop of ag-1 worked together to fill
the nutritional gaps in your diet
support energy and focus aid with gut
health and digestion and support a
healthy immune system effectively
replacing multiple products or pills
with one healthy delicious drink join
the movement of athletes moms dads
rookies first-timers and everyone in
between taking ownership of their daily
health and focusing on the nutritional
products they really need in the
simplest manner possible to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew to take
control of your health and give a ag-1 a
try for most of us learning a second
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point in our
academic careers all right i took
spanish and i started in eighth grade
went to like 11th
and by 11th grade i was hitting d's in
that spanish show i wasn't even doing
that great in english now thanks to
babel the language learning app that
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
there's an addictively fun and easy way
to learn a new language whether you'll
be traveling abroad connecting in a
deeper way with family or you just have
some free time babel teaches bite-sized
language lessons that you'll actually
use in the real world i chose babel
because i'd gone to mexico and i
remember taking these classes and i was
like man i don't know
anything outside of cockahuates and
calcetine so babel's 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over a hundred language experts their
teaching method has been scientifically
proven to be effective with babel you
can choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel's speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and your accent there are
so many ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can also access
podcasts games videos stories and even
live classes plus it comes with a 20 day
money back guarantee all right start
your new language learning journey today
with babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you're
gonna get an additional three months for
free that's six months for the price of
three just go to babel.com and use promo
code honeydew that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code honeydew babble language for life
so so now this guy's hanging on the hose
at the top of a the buckets is deep and
now he's right at the top right where i
don't want him
and so i kind of push him down as i'm
pushing him down i'm seeing the bubbles
coming up
and i'm like this is devastating but it
was quite the life lesson for me not for
him
and
this [ __ ] thing maggots no in its
lower bodies it just keeps climbing
it just keeps coming up
it's like the jason voorhees of squirrel
dump
i mean if he came up one more time with
a goalie mask on i would have flipped
out
it won't go man it won't
die i love it but i'm sitting here going
i've never seen anything in my life
clinging wanting to live so bad
and now i'm sitting here thinking do i
pull it out now because i'm so
like even though i know it's it's die
it's been eaten alive you can't once the
maggots are in there what are you gonna
do pull them you can't save it
and i'm just like it was it was like
devastating man because i had to
this thing that wanted so death even it
probably knew it was it was
in pain and it was injured you know
animals know that but it just kept
coming up and i eventually just had to
like hold the little guy down
and it was
did it work how long did it take well
finally i had to drop a cinder block in
the box
i finally was it scratching the [ __ ] out
of you and clawed no it was on the hose
i was holding the hose and it was coming
up to the top of
how dare you
you were two handed under there
no i wasn't i wasn't holding it down die
bastard
die maggot freak no it was it was uh it
was but but but
it made me think on a serious note like
just how
precious life is like to see that that
little guy who was just start it was
probably only three four weeks old maybe
five i don't know but
it wanted to live so bad
and i think about humans and i think
about
god bless people who become suicidal or
become terminally ill or people who say
i don't want to live anymore and just
just
it stuck with me really i still have a
crystal clear vision of that thing
struggling so hard
to live and it was horrible because i
couldn't let it because the alternative
was
being eaten alive from like the lower
part of its
body you could already see the flesh and
turned brown and it was rotted you could
smell it and i was just like it doesn't
know
and
i'm telling you man it
it somehow instilled to me despite how
hard it was to do it instilled to me
how precious life is and how every day
we've got to get out and just claw and
embrace it and and
because in a way metaphorically the
world eats away at us from the inside on
psychological levels and things like
that but
but there was something really profound
that that stuck with me as horrible as
it was to put him down i hope i did the
right thing and put him out of his
misery i think he did yeah but but but
in doing that it that little creature
taught me a lesson about just the
sanctity of life and the the power of
being alive and to see something that
obviously they don't think at the level
humans do but to see its desire to just
want to live and you know it's
heartbreaking but it was very powerful
on it
it's still it's one of the few things in
life that i think about that really
tortures me to be honest i think animals
teach you a lot about death you know my
brother told me this story this is
an unfortunate one that you'll probably
enjoy but uh a neighbor dog of theirs
got rabies and it ran and it buried
itself under it dug a hole and buried
itself under the front sidewalk of my
brother's house so it's gonna it's going
under the house to die
but it's it's
today
it ain't gonna die yeah for a long time
so they have to kill it
right the neighbor comes over and they
have to put a shotgun underneath the
house and they shoot this damn dog to
kill this dog and now
they got to get the [ __ ] thing out of
there and they're fishing like trying to
lasso a paw anything they can yeah
they're taking
it took them hours to do this wow
because this dog decided i'm going under
and i don't want to this is how i want
to go you know but that's interesting
because rabies is a
disease that
makes animals like aggressive mm-hmm it
was aggressive but it went under the
[ __ ] house and wasn't letting you get
it like they couldn't pull it out
but why wouldn't it just want to come
out and like attack them i don't know
maybe it didn't have rabies after all
maybe maybe you're on to something maybe
it was just depressed
maybe it just didn't like the way it was
being raised
like [ __ ] these guys i don't get walks i
don't get wet dog food
it could have been that's sidewalks
looking around i'm only reporting yeah
i'm just telling you the story i know
wow yeah it's
anything anytime you lose an animal man
have you ever hit an animal on the road
oh man i'll tell you what i've hit two
that that really stuck with me oh i had
a cat one time wow
i remember seeing in my rear view just
back spinning on the road and i was like
oh man i felt awful but this other time
i hit a bird
and it flew right into the [ __ ] grill
and i nailed it now i'm i'm leaving la
to go to big bear and i drive straight
shot get up there about two hours and
i'm like
man that [ __ ] bird's probably all
over the front of this [ __ ] car if
not it went in that grill and it cooked
all in there oh god and i go around to
the front of the car and we get there
and there's nothing i was like oh man
and i'm waiting to pop the hood to see
this mutilated bird all over the engine
and yeah harlan williams i popped that
[ __ ] hood and that bird flew off
flew off now look it was two hours away
where from wherever the [ __ ] it was but
it had a new lease on life
i just kept picturing that bird had to
be hiding in that hot ass engine yeah
for two hours and stayed away from all
the moving parts and everything yeah it
killed that [ __ ] thing that's a
running back obviously flew in that
through the grill stay it was a miracle
how big was it was it a little late
like a little
wow another time uh my stepson over
there our cat
it [ __ ] brought a bird in the house
yeah and his mom kept saying it's a bird
i was like it's not a bird i was like oh
[ __ ] it is a bird so i you know cats
want to bring you their their prize and
like look what i brought you so i rolled
it up in a little dish towel and i said
to derek i go you can come with me if
you want there's i'm going to be
straight up with it because he was young
at the time and i was like this thing's
either dead and nothing's going to
happen or you're about to witness a
miracle and he's like i'm going to stay
here i'm not going i said okay i went
out on the sidewalk and i rolled that
[ __ ] towel out and that bird i'll
never forget it it it got up it shook
itself off like a dog you know what i
mean and then off into the night wow
i've had a couple lucky ones that's good
yeah i had one once where i laughed so
hard i almost
like went off the road and that sounds
really mean but sometimes life
throws you things and you don't have any
control and this is a horrible story
but i couldn't control you know
sometimes when you see an old lady trip
or someone walk into a window or
something like that physical humor
and you know they're in pain but you
can't it just triggers i think humans
are triggered by physical
comedy or tragedy or whatever you want
to call it
and i was driving once and i hit like a
ground squirrel i was driving a van
but i just clipped it like i didn't run
over it but it's like it's like the side
of my tire just kind of must have hit it
in the head or something
and i looked in the rear view mirror and
it was convulsing on the road like it
was like like spasming out like all like
it was just like it was just like it
looked like an electric cable was loose
and just seeing that
i couldn't i burst out like i felt so
guilty but it was it just looked
physically so funny
like it was just it was looked like it
was having a seizure and it was just
flipping around in it
just weird what about in toronto and
because in maryland especially out in
the county we had a ton of deer did you
ever oh yeah you're running tons of deer
i never ran into a deer but
my um lady i consider my mom just hit a
[ __ ] deer and she's lucky that thing
went hit the windshield and then flew
over the
wow the roof
and they're just at it
no this one died this one didn't make it
but a lot of times they will they'll
[ __ ] your car up no you're running yeah
there's a whole
out in the midwest there that the
insurance industry runs on deer hits i i
actually was researching it once and and
there's a huge amount of deaths every
year from deer kills and there's
something like
300 million dollars worth of damage
caused by deers every year it's a huge
thing i once read somewhere in uh that
there were more
car accidents caused by deer in
pennsylvania than car hitting cars
probably yeah it's nuts they're nice man
they're they're not smart they just run
out
clueless
so
we've shared two animal deaths now this
is an episode about three deaths yeah
that's what we're gonna call this three
death three deaths with harlan williams
nice um
share the third death with us please
wow the third one is a human death
and
we've all experienced death we've all
been to a funeral we've all
but i don't know how many of your
viewers have watched somebody die
and that's uh that's a powerful thing
and a few years back probably i guess
about three maybe four years ago
i watched a guy die
and
someone you knew it wasn't someone i
knew it was a very unusual circumstance
i was at the burning man festival
and at the on the second last night of
the burning man festival they have a
giant like a 70 80 foot wooden man
that they light on fire that's that's
called the
the the concept i'm burning man is when
the man goes on fire it it releases all
your baggage and all your inner demons
and
they're supposed to all go up with the
smoke and
um
it's a very ritualistic thing you've got
70 000 people in the desert
and
on the second last night they all form a
giant circle around the man there's a
it's quite a distance because they know
there's gonna they're gonna light it on
fire but i've seen the pictures of that
thing it's massive it's massive but
being there the energy is unbelievable
and i don't know you've probably seen
like the original king kong or even one
of the remakes there's the scene where
fay ray or wherever the girl is in the
movie is is tied to the trees and king
kong's about to come through the trees
and all the all the natives are playing
the drums and waving the fire and so at
burning man
pre-lighting the man
they have all this fanfare they have
they have big rows of people with drums
and they have people twirling fire
torches and marching with torches it's
all orchestrated of course but it's very
primal it feels like
some kind of you know ancient tribal
ritual almost and the rhythm of the
[Music]
it's you're waiting for this giant you
know they they lift the arms the man
moves and so it it's almost very king
kongish you know and you're
kind of caught in this this kind of
euphoria of it and uh
and so they obviously make you sit back
a certain amount because of the intense
heat this this when they light the man
the flames grew up 100 feet high
you know 80 90 100 feet wide it's a huge
inferno
how close do you can you get and start
to feel that
let's just put this way we we were
sitting like back the length of probably
three quarters of a football field and
and and on that night we almost had to
stand up and move back because the heat
was it's so intense damn okay you know
you're in a flat desert and there's
nothing around and there's no safety
fences they have a few
they have a few fire people like in kind
of like asbestos fire gear like kind of
standing closer like just kind of
setting up a perimeter
and this is my
third time at burning man and so it kind
of
oh bless
um i'm sorry to clear my throat no
problem but i kind of
you kind of know what you're getting and
it's it's really a beautiful event
actually and
and um as the man started to burn
um probably mid burn before it collapsed
uh out of all these 70 000 people some
guy sitting right by us just stood up
and ran towards the burning man but now
he's like right in front of us
and he's sprinting like toward it he's
sprinting but have you ever seen these
guys at sporting events when they jump
on the field some of them
they don't know where they're going so
they're jumping and they're they're kind
of getting the fans all pumped up it's
it's like a game
so this guy's now doing this with the
people around the fire guys and they're
trying to and they almost grab them and
he's almost like prancing it looked like
it looked like almost like a fairy tale
like watching a sprite dancing in front
of a flame and he he looked like he was
having so much fun and he was eluding
them and the crowd was even cheering
they're like yeah every time he got away
this went on for about maybe a minute
and a half
and then in the midst of his uh his
euphoria and kind of the the
the energy he whipped up he just like
turned towards the fire
ran and literally did this and dove in
no
dove in like right in front of us
and i instantly went
oh he's dead you know because it just
just to breathe in that heat yeah it
would incinerate your lungs
and so he go and the fire guys are like
the whole crowd
silent and and one of the a couple of
these brave fire guys they they went in
and at the very
tip because they were wearing this stuff
and they dragged him out and you just
saw this smoldering body being dragged
along the ground and then they got him
far and just let him go and an ambulance
came and so they call it burning men now
[Laughter]
now when his dog came together
i like how your comment already starts
with my dog
listen i have to be careful because i'm
telling you we have an owl in a
neighborhood my dog goes out at night
and pees and poops i gotta i stand out
there and make sure that i picked your
dog you met her she's out there oh that
yeah
i'll take her right off i know i stand
out there with her my dog wasn't much uh
smaller than that i'm out there yeah i
don't let her go oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's quick i know they can before i can
even
turn around and go on i know they just
swoop all right sorry my joke about
burning man um that's so you watch this
guy dive in and do you can i i mean
does he just incinerate or do you hear
screams do you hear nothing it was sort
of silent and and it was funny because
the crowd went from chanting for the guy
to everyone just went silent it was like
this shock
i remember seven well only half of us
saw because the others were on the other
side but a lot of people witnessed this
and
and there was no screaming and he didn't
he didn't ignite but they they pulled
him out and it was so intense that you
could see his body was slow you're right
that smoke and heat and everything oh
yeah just melt your lungs yeah you
couldn't even breathe holy [ __ ] and so
we went from having this incredible
festive fun week to this moment i was
sitting with about 15 16 other people
and
it was just like
and again it it
it really was hard to make sense of it
because this guy looked like he was on
cloud nine you know it looked like
and we don't know if it was drug induced
or he was just suicide but he looked
like the happiest guy he'd ever seen
and in the blink of an eye he was gone
and it was uh
it was really weird and the people i
were with i could tell everyone was just
scatterbrained we're all everyone was
just like
you didn't know where to look you didn't
know what to say and and
i kind of took a bit of a leadership
stance in that moment
and i knew that at least for myself
psychologically this was going to be
something hard to process and
and so i just grabbed everyone
instinctively i said i said i don't know
if any of you guys believe in god i
don't know if you pray if you what you
believe but i said
i think we're all going to need this and
i said let's hold hands
and i said a prayer for that guy because
it was like
you know you think about how we feel
about passing on some of us picture the
soul moving into another afterlife or
another portal and
and but that's always after the fact you
know but it was right here and i felt
like
i felt like maybe we need to
come together and and help this guy or
at least acknowledge this guy or say
something and
i know i needed it i don't if the other
ones might have thought
why did you need it
because i
it was it was a man it was a person you
know and to me people are so powerful
like human beings
we have we have 20 million stories going
on
every second we're alive even just
sitting here even when you're sitting
quiet you everybody's mind is processing
and thinking and creating and
we have these long lives that you know
maybe they're short and caught into the
context of the universe but
but the things we all experience whether
it's the first time you pee the first
time you get a job the first time you
think hateful thoughts the first time
you think loving thought like were were
these detailed intricate stories
and to see one just vanish in the blink
of an eye it's i didn't know his story
but i knew he had millions of stories
and and so i felt like i needed to help
and then crazy also that the greatest
story he could probably tell is one that
he's not going to be around to tell
yeah maybe you know what i mean maybe
yeah what a story to be like oh dove in
the [ __ ] burning man one time like
how are you here to tell that story
i know
it's weird it and it's a big story and
yeah so it uh it's just something
um
i believe there's a bigger power of
bigger energy out there and agreed
and and whether you want to call it god
or the forces of the universe or gravity
or air or love whatever you but i really
believe in in the power of
human energy and just energy in the
universe and
and somehow i felt like it was important
for me and i i thought even if these
people don't believe in anything maybe
maybe this moment of us praying for him
or channeling energy for him will
will
later on come around and be helpful to
them i even said that to him i said i i
don't know if you guys will need this
now but maybe it'll help down the road
and i don't know if it did or not but it
helped me i mean i i was able to release
a lot of sorrow and confusion and
and uh sadness for this person you know
but then maybe there was something in it
too where
he wanted to go maybe it was time to go
and i also
thought i tried to get in his head and i
go what if this is the most beautiful
way what a way to go
a hundred foot inferno you know how we
all sit at a campfire we just stare
we're mesmerized and i thought what if
this is the opening for him to go to the
next place and so i didn't i didn't
chalk it as up as i know oh he was
depressed or he maybe maybe that was the
most beautiful
what if that also is the portal to
wherever the [ __ ] he's going next you
gotta dive into that [ __ ] shed
that thing and you're over there now
it's sometimes it's you know i'll tell
you a story and it goes back to animals
i i was on safari in africa years ago oh
man you did that i would oh yeah
i'm scared i've done it a few times and
and
me and my cousin went out one morning
just in an open land rover by ourselves
and and our and our guide and
we're fortunate enough we're we're in
one of these remote safari camps where
it's not 30 people and a thing clicking
cam and we were in a place where you're
allowed to go off-road and just drive
through the wilderness you don't have to
stick to the trail so it was amazing and
we happened to come upon two
male lions that had just made a kill
like literally they probably took it
down five minutes before we got then
they were in the middle of eating a
wildebeest carcass and
and our guide pulled up and stopped the
truck and these two male lions just
stood up and walked halfway towards us
and i had the video camera going and i'm
like oh this is cool but then
but then they just locked on me like
their their big golden eyes just locked
on me
and i'm telling you right my hand
started shaking
the power in those beasts like that
stare the the majesty and the intensity
and
and the unbridled viciousness they don't
know that they're vicious they just know
that they're wired to live and hunt and
kill and it's not there's no malice
there's no cruelty that's what they're
wired to do and so
i was just like but then i had a moment
where i i saw these two things that if
they wanted to be in our open-air
vehicle they they could have ran and
been in on us and probably in about two
and a half seconds
but they don't do that because they see
the vehicle as something other than
flash and they don't they don't really
get it
but something in me went i saw these
beautiful strong tall thing with the
manes and the golden eyes and i'm not i
told my cousin this like last time we
were together and he goes what's wrong
with you i said i said kevin you know
there was a moment
when i thought about putting down the
camera
and i just wanted to jump out and rush
those things
and grab them and go if this is how i
die what a way to go how did he die oh
he attacked a lion
he attacked he is a child a [ __ ] king
of the beast two of them
and i'm not kidding i thought what a
[ __ ] way
and see the look of their eyes like what
the [ __ ] is that a guy from the valley
just and grab that and ride it i mean
they'd be chomping down right
what a way to go you know what i mean it
would be a way to go so who knows maybe
this guy this this this fire was his was
beautiful to him
but for for me it was it was very hard
to watch a human soul go in that moment
and have no say in it and have to be
witness to it and not even sure what's
really happening it's not like that
guy's screaming and darting the whole
way like oh my god he looked happy he
looked engaged i'll share an animal
death with you that i think is one of
the most beautiful amazing unique deaths
um
i would say of probably any animal to be
honest um
i don't know if you remember the pitcher
randy johnson yeah uh in spring training
for the arizona diamondbacks when he was
pitching he accidentally killed a dove
yeah he flew right through right into
his ball yeah right and he killed it
yeah and the feathers blew up everywhere
looked like a fireworks it was it died
in its own fireworks show and i think
about that dove all the time first of
all dove is a symbol of peace this is a
peaceful anime [ __ ] randy johnson up for
a while i think he's got a company about
it now or something but
i bet he doesn't bathe with dove soap
i'll tell you that
it's spring training i think about it
all the time
and i wonder if that bird among its
group however it communicated they're
like maybe it had [ __ ] cancer maybe
it wasn't gonna make it and they were
like nah man this is spring training he
was like nah it's my day today and i
think that bird timed that [ __ ] out and
built it into its own you know how many
doves have been killed by a randy
johnson fastball
one how many doves have been on this
planet probably billions right
how many doves out there can say yeah
it wasn't an accident i took it from an
all-star
the best
wow yeah and went out in its own
fireworks
but that is you talk about lights out
it was lights that burr was just so and
then just black like tony soprano yeah i
mean just slight switch oh yeah there
were feathers it looked like a fat chick
sat on a pillow at bed bath and beyond
and it just
boom
it's a galore that's a glorious
beautiful death yeah i guess i hear what
you're saying
to that like
yeah you'd be an absolute [ __ ] to do it
but what a way to [ __ ] go yeah ripped
a lot i and also
like again i'm i'm reminded of the power
of these [ __ ] beasts because i there
was a video i saw i think it was an
indian guy that had jumped down into a
tiger
cage in a zoo oh yeah and he was just
sitting there crying and they they sort
of looked at him for a while yeah like
what and then a couple of them look each
other like the [ __ ] let's eat it
they grabbed that man
one of them by the neck and i mean
sprinted like
galloping to the back of that thing this
is a grown adult man by the neck with
just its jaws like it was a rag
and then they all ate them alive yeah
yeah
[ __ ] it yeah
yeah it's it's uh it's it's strange it's
it's powerful and just
death is uh
it's uh it's it's weird it's tough how
you process it and uh it's something we
all have to
see and deal with and i remember when i
was a kid
the first time i ever saw a dead body i
had to go to my grandfather's funeral i
was probably nine and i remember just
seeing his body laying there and it was
an open casket and i was a little kid so
i didn't and i just started like patting
his head like i said oh grandpa you know
like i couldn't believe he was there but
just motionless and i'm just like
you know it's weird and it's just it's
very strange yeah the first dead body i
saw was my great grandma great grandma
cookie in her [ __ ] parlor back in the
day in their house there was an old
italian
lady they came over from italy and she
died and they laid her out in the
[ __ ] house for the funeral that was
like the viewing oh she's coming by the
house and she's laid out and and she's
sleeping in there you know what i mean i
remember i remember them sending me up
to sleep with a cookie monster i just
that cookie monster [ __ ] stuck with
me but that was the first ever i
remember touching and feeling how cold
just
fake and the rosary wrapped around the
hands and
just like well i don't know i don't know
i i get it but i don't [ __ ] get it
yeah like i get that this seems final
everyone's black wearing black and
crying and yeah but they'll be laid out
in the [ __ ] house in the old days
like in the parlor i'm like what are you
[ __ ] what in the house and that was
before scotchgard
it was before i mean the stains
god
but it was an italian out so it's
probably plastic on everything anyways
what an episode harlan
all right so before we wrap up here now
that we've talked about quite a bit of
death yeah yeah um i ask every guest if
i can remember and sometimes i forget
but i remember what advice you would
give to your 16 year old self
what advice i would give to my 16 year
old self
i would say
it's interesting ryan because i've lived
one of these lives where i've really
i came up with a motto when i was young
because i saw a lot of people when i was
young just letting life pass them by or
consume them and i
i came up with my own motto
live life don't let life live you i like
that and i'm one of these people in life
that went after
all my dreams and attained most of them
and it was
merely because i decided at a young age
to go after
what i wanted
and mold my life into what i wanted it
to be
i didn't wait for life to
happen to me i i pursued life i pursued
the things i wanted in life and so
i would say to my younger self
live life don't let life live you dude
that's [ __ ] great yeah that's great
advice yeah thank you for doing the show
thank you for being so open and honest
and finding something to laugh about in
that ugly ass uh mess well you know
that's what i liked about your show
because i knew it would be tough to talk
about some of this thing but in closing
i'll say this you know i've never been
to a funeral where i didn't lean over
and crack a joke to someone
humor and darkness is what helps make us
get through being humor and sometimes it
feels insensitive to laugh about it but
there's a there's a deeper psychological
mythology but methodology behind
laughing
at the dark stuff absolutely today was
actually brian a little therapeutic for
me because
these three things are things that play
in my mind a lot and to
come out and sit here with you and laugh
at them and and release
look at them in a lighter way it's
actually helpful so
thank you brother um please again
promote everything and anything you'd
like oh yeah so you can um you can buy
one of my uh hand-drawn t-shirts at
harbling.com h-a-r-b-l-i-n-g.com
and if we're sold out of the actual
print uh the actual real drawing you can
order print
and i guess uh check my website
harleywilliams.com for my stand-up
comedy tours
and lastly uh hit me up on instagram
harlan williams i'm always putting up
funny videos
because while we're in this life i try
to offer laughter to people and that's
what i put on my instagram
i love it dude awesome uh as always ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you